feeling as good as i should be feeling
and you know you just got to stay on top
of things and see what the trainers say
and um
just keep getting treatment
is this just one of those just wear and
tear the regular season type of things
or is this something new
it's football
we'll update it as we go through the
week here and um
yeah
depend on how it goes that there's an
adjustment we need to make we'll make it
[Music]
cam newton limited both days in practice
this week abdomen injury and bill
belichick's never going to come out and
say what his plans are or what may be
happening you'll see who the quarterback
is when it's time for the offense to
take the first snap but if it's not cam
newton jared stidham next man up and
it's a big few days for the new england
patriots peter they're five and six
they're in la for back-to-back games
sunday against the chargers thursday
night against the rams and cam newton
not that he's lighting it up
statistically but he's kind of
stabilized after that rough spot after
he had coveted 19 and and and they're a
team where if you're the steelers if
you're the chiefs if you're any team
that has designs on advancing into the
postseason and winning games there you
don't want one of your games to be
new england patriots
yeah it's a
that's that's one of the one of the odd
things mike because you never know what
you're going to get out of the patriots
it can be a real noble effort
uh you know for 50 or 55 minutes and a
loss like happened at kansas city
you know it can be the kind of game
back and forth and back and forth and
then you end up winning in the end
like against arizona or you could get
blown out
so that is the odd thing this year about
playing the patriots look i think if cam
newton can play he will play bill
belichick saw jared stidham um in kansas
city earlier this year he's seen him
and i'm not saying he's given up on him
forever but i just don't think he trusts
jared stidham with the playoffs on the
line
not that cam newton has given you a lot
to trust him either but i just think
right now
if there's any way cam newton can go
he's going to
go yeah i think so too and again if they
get to the playoffs you've got all that
playoff experience institutionally in
new england cam newton has been to the
top of the mountain even though he
wasn't quite able to grab the flag a few
years ago as quarterback of the carolina
panthers he's definitely got the
experience in the postseason game
stidhum doesn't and you want him to be
healthy for as many games as he possibly
can play
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports